-Our first guests tonight
are two very talented actors
of stage and screen.
You know her from the iconic
sitcom "Will & Grace"
and him from NBC's
"Parks and Recreation."
They star in the animated series
"The Great North,"
which airs Sunday nights,
on Fox.
Please welcome back to the sho
Megan Mullally
and Nick Offerman.
How are you?
-Good. Hello.
-The Liz and Dick of today
-Yeah, the --
Which one is the --
Which one is the Liz,
is my question?
-That's for you guys to decide
We don't --
We're not gonna tell you
how to live your marriage.
-That's what makes it
more modern.
I actually love
the Liz and Dick reference
I think it's so amazing.
I've used Lunt and Fontanne,
so you tell your writer
that he's on the cutting edg
compared to me.
-Oh, the person who wrote that's
way too old to be a writer
[ Laughter ]
-Did that -- Did that
not come from Shoemaker?
-It was Shoemaker.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was absolutely --
a producer came up with that
That's what we call people
too old to write.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Nick, you were actually -
The last time we had an audience
here, you were with us.
You were here on --
on March 11th.
So it is lovely
to see you again,
albeit under
far worse circumstances.
-You too.
It was very strange.
We were uncomfortably, like,
laughing and touching elbows
-Yeah.
-"I guess -- I guess this is
gonna be a real thing."
-Yeah.
I feel like the last day
any of us did shows,
we would not look back on
proudly, like,
"Ha ha ha! Elbows!
This'll be over tomorrow."
And then it was like,
"Get out of the city!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, you guys are back out
You're working,
which is very exciting.
You're doing an animated show,
which I know
you can do from home.
That is not, of course,
all you're doing.
And I want to ask real quick
are you happy with the way
you've been animated
on this show?
That's you, Nick.
-I am.
I mean, you know,
anyone who's worn a flannel coat
that's wool on the outside
and shearling on the insid
would tell you that's clearl
a slimming outfit.
-Yes.
-And I look like Cher, so...
And there's never anything
bad about that.
-No.
Absolutely.
I think they both did
very well by you.
This is very exciting, Megan
You are going to be doing
"Anything Goes" in London,
correct?
-Yes.
You know, God willing
and the COVID don't rise or --
that's really terrible.
And that's on television now
But that's fine.
Yes.
-Thanks, Shoemaker.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he wrote that.
-Yeah.
-He wrote that.
I'm supposed to go over ther
and do "Anything Goes."
So it's supposed to open
at the end of July,
and I'm taking tap classes
I'm learning
all the tap choreography.
So I've been
tapping my troubles away.
-And now, do you do all the ta
out of the house,
or is Nick sort of --
Okay.
So there's no, like,
tapping in the home.
-No.
It's an empty dance studio
and it's me and this woman
who's teaching it to me.
And it's pretty fun,
I have to say.
-You guys met on stage.
I, of course, knew that --
Nick, I knew you were
doing stuff in Chicago.
But you had just
come out to L.A.,
and you guys
were in a play together.
Was it love at first sight
-Well, we have
kind of two versions of this
For me, Megan says yes,
that, for me,
it was love at first sight
But I -- I was living
in someone's dirt basement
and Megan had just finishe
her first two seasons
of "Will & Grace."
So we were
in such different places
that I had, like,
crazy "Prince and the Pauper,"
like "Princess and the Pea" --
I had a real class struggle.
I had to get through two weeks
of, like, inoculation
to sort of realize
that Megan was --
that I was a human like Megan.
[ Laughter ]
Because I really, like, placed
her so high on a pedestal.
So I had the feelings.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
Am I --
You know, are we sparking?
Is this canoodling?"
[ Laughter ]
But I was like,
"No, it can't be.
She's, like,
a professional actress."
But, eventually, uh...
it worked out.
-Did he ask you
for your number, Megan?
-Oh, no.
He, um -- He had called --
The number I put on the --
The number I gave out
to everybody on the call sheet
was my fax number
because I didn't want --
I didn't want creeps like this
to have my number, you know?
So I didn't know that he'd lef
a message on my fax machine,
asking me to go out
and hear this cowboy band
until two weeks later.
So for two weeks, he thought
he'd been completely iced.
But then, I finally heard it
-Yeah.
-It was --
It was his dulcet tones,
'cause he really does
have a good speaking voice
except when he's in character.
-Did he --
And did you have to sort o
introduce him
to the finer points of --
of society?
-Oh, God. The first time
we went to a restaurant,
he tucked his napkin
into the bib of his overalls
[ Laughter ]
-Which is how it's done.
That's how Jed Clampett did it
on "Beverly Hillbillies."
-And he turned out fine.
-If you're working class
and you end up in Los Angele
at a fancy dinner,
you tuck your napkin
into your collar.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys,
you also have a podcast called
"In Bed with Nick and Megan.
Now, I have always found
you guys to be a couple
that is very happy
to share the innermost details
of your relationship.
Have you found any boundarie
that you haven't wanted
to cross yet,
or is it the same as it always
was, even in podcast form?
-I mean, it's pretty full-on
because the thing is that,
no matter how much we say
about our relationship,
nobody really knows.
You know?
They don't know.
-This is fascinating to me
Megan, you found --
Because you say that,
and I think that's true, but you
actually found old letters of --
of your mother's.
And so, this is actually -
You're actually finding ou
more than anyone, I think,
most normal people ever find out
about their family.
-It's kind of unbelievable
really.
I mean, I have found giant bin
packed with letters
written to my mother, like, love
letters written to my mother
I mean, I'm talking about 75
letters just -- just from guys
And then, another giant bin of
letters written to my father
So they saved everything.
And so, I have love letter
written to my father
and I have all the letters
from his mother and his father
and his brother and sister
And I just found them.
So that's what I'm doing,
like, full-time every day
is reading these.
-Were they a passionate couple
your parents?
-Well, this is their -- it's
before they knew each other.
-Got you.
-So they're all things
that were written to them
before they knew each other.
-That's fascinating.
-It's kind of unbelievable
-It's crazy.
And it's pretty also
embarrassing for us in that --
Because this is before,
obviously, texting,
but even before you comfortabl
would call someone on the phone.
And so, this is just
the correspondence of people
in their late teens
and early 20s.
And even the dumb ones
are so, like, well-written
and there's an erudition
that's like, "Oh, my God."
You know, this is us being like,
"Oh, my God.
Did you see 'Scooby-Doo'?"
And these people are writing
about, like, the war effort.
-It's all wartime, also.
But it's very humanizing,
because, you know, everybody -
you always think, like,
"People back then didn't hav
emotions like we do."
Of course they did.
But also, there's some hot goss.
I mean, the hot-goss quotien
is off the charts.
And there's a couple of
kind of shocking --
You know, there's a letter
to my father
from this, like, real floozy
And there's this really
disgusting letter that my father
wrote to a guy friend
and never mailed
that's so gross.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
I mean, it's bad enough
finding letters
that your parents wrote
but the ones that even they knew
they shouldn't send.
[ Laughter ]
-Totally.
-They say really satisfyin
things like,
"I'm gonna come see you
this weekend,
and we are gonna 'get tight.'"
-It is always a delight
to lay eyes on you both.
Thank you so much
for making time for us.
And I do hope
we can do it again soon.
-Thanks, Seth.
You too.
-Let's do it in person.
-That sounds like a deal.
"The Great North"
airs Sundays, on Fox.